la russie invite les talibans à des
pourparlers et la rencontre aura lieu le
20 octobre à moscou le but tenter
d'organiser l'aide humanitaire sur place
une proposition alors qu'il y a vingt
ans jour pour jour la guerre en
afghanistan débutait une offensive
lancée par george deubeuliou bush en
réponse aux attentats du 11 septembre en
quelques semaines la coalition
internationale dirigée par les états
unis a renversé le gouvernement aux
taliban de kaboul est les talibans qui
ont repris le pouvoir le 15 août dernier
après le retrait des forces américaines
beaucoup d'auditions devant le congrès
américain ces dernières semaines on a vu
par exemple anthony blinken mais aussi
les plus hauts gradés du pentagone
devant répondre à cette interrogation
comment expliquer le fiasco du retrait
des troupes américaines d'afghanistan
beaucoup de critiques sur le manque
d'anticipation et puis aussi une
certaine polémique parce que des
généraux affirment qu'ils avaient averti
les autorités politiques à des risques
écouté par exemple chef d'état major des
armées c'était il ya quelques jours à
l'automne 2001 mon analyse était qu un
retrait accéléré sans remplir des
conditions spécifiques et nécessaire qui
risquait de faire perdre le gains
substantiels réalisés en afghanistan
nuire est potentiellement à la
crédibilité mondiale des etats-unis et
pourrait précipiter un effondrement
général des forces de sécurité afghanes
et du gouvernement afghan entraînant une
prise de pouvoir complète par les
talibans ou une guerre civile générale
le général le mark muller affirme aussi
que cet échec stratégique est en réalité
le résultat de l'accumulation de faits
depuis 20 ans d'où cette deuxième
interrogation est ce que finalement
cette guerre en afghanistan valait la
peine au vu des résultats et bien à
cette question karl eikenberry répond
non lui qui a commandé des troupes en
afghanistan avant même de devenir
l'ambassadeur américain dans le pays
pendant deux ans d'autres gradés de
l'armée américaine admettent aujourd'hui
que les erreurs ont en fait commencé dès
le début de cette guerre avec une
méconnaissance de l'environnement
méconnaissance des enjeux et puis plus
généralement un manque de vision à moyen
et long terme de la situation sur place
il faut aussi rappeler qu'en 2019 déjà
le washington post dévoiler les
afghanistan and paper's des documents
jusque là jamais dévoiler où le public a
pu découvrir que les autorités
américaines savaient en fait depuis
longtemps que cette guerre était
ingagnable contrairement à ce qu'ils ont
affirmé publiquement pendant des années
et puis si la pertinence de cette guerre
est aujourd'hui remise en question c'est
aussi parce qu'elle a constitué un
véritable gouffre financier pour les
états unis avec un coût total estimé à
plus de 2000 milliards de dollars une
somme qui continue d'augmenter parce que
cette guerre a été contracté avec de la
dette il y à des taux d'intérêt à
rembourser au moins jusqu'à l'année 2050
évidemment le plus dramatique dans cette
guerre en afghanistan reste le bilan
humain de 1500 soldats américains ont
été tués quatre mille civils américains
ont également perdu la vie et puis il ne
faut pas oublier les dizaines de
milliers de civils afghans qui ont eux
aussi perdu la vie pendant ces vingt
années de guerre et puis on dit souvent
que l'opinion américaine était
majoritairement favorables à la fin de
cette guerre en afghanistan ce qui est
vrai mais c'est à nuancer avec les
derniers événements qui ont eu lieu cet
été puisque un sondage publié cette
semaine affirme que seulement 28 % des
américains interrogés soutiennent le
retrait total des troupes d'afghanistan
50% d'entre eux auraient en fait préféré
qu'on laisse un petit peu de soldats
encore sur place pour quelques temps